hi there just come home from dinner with
some friends play golf today my wife is
playing some piano here i'm gonna go
down and watch the vancouver canucks
game that i recorded
uh you know when i look at this day 89 i
have to admit that i feel a sense of
relief
tomorrow will be day 90.
and um
that'll be it
all i may have to wait till tuesday to
have my last conversation in korea
what can i say
that i haven't already said in 88 videos
um
i feel great i feel i've achieved
momentum
one little thing i asked our
my transcriber to do i realized that
because my
my podcast the kim yong-hao podcast are
30 to 50 minutes long each
that it it slows down the system on the
ipad
so i've now asked her to break those up
into eight to ten minutes segments
and so we will be re-uploading all those
lessons
into our library at link in sort of
eight to ten minute length
segments which will make it easier
uh we discussed it in the office the
other day and apparently i'm the only
one who will even tackle 30 to 50 minute
long lessons most people seem to prefer
shorter lessons
so that's going to happen
and i think it'll be easier for me with
shorter lessons things happen faster on
our system there's less calculation
going on in the background
uh at link
uh one other thing that is kind of
interesting uh we had a person on our
forum at link today asking about how i
dealt with cases in russian
and she pointed out that it doesn't
prevent her from understanding russian
but she has trouble utilizing the cases
and of course i explained that in my
experience it's not difficult to
understand the principles behind the use
of cases it's difficult to remember all
the specific usages and exceptions and
which prepositions take which case and
all the various specific you know verbs
that take different cases and so forth
but none of that prevents you from
reading and listening and understanding
it's just that when you go to speak it's
difficult to
remember all these rules and also
remember all the case endings very very
difficult and i simply said you know i
never really much worried about it
because most of my activity was
listening and reading and then listening
and reading i'm gradually getting more
and more familiar with the language
and i spent a lot of time with examples
the examples that are generated that
link
i tag for cases and and i realized that
the same is true with my korean i and
maybe i'm different from most people i
don't really worry about what i'm unable
to do
when speaking the language i don't worry
about the mistakes that i make i don't
worry about and i should say by the way
that at this stage i can say
categorically that russian is more
difficult than korean it is easier to
make a mistake in russian in terms of
cases
and uh
verbs of motion and
you know the uh aspects of verbs it's
easier to make a mistake
in russian than in korean
uh but in in either case there are usage
patterns there
that you aren't gonna get right until
you have a lot of practice and so that's
not only just an issue of cases it's an
issue of which word to use or which
phrase is appropriate for this example
and of course in korean you have the
issue of of politeness levels and all of
these things just take a lot of getting
used to and so because i'm prepared to
put a lot of time into listening and
reading and getting used to the language
that way
and then i'm prepared to stumble
as i start to express myself more
although i wrote and i had it corrected
so i'm starting to write
uh and i i you know i do speak but i do
so with mistakes and it doesn't bother
me so
uh
just to kind of reinforce what i've said
all along that i'm i'm happy that i've
built up enough momentum in my career
that i can enjoy interesting content as
i pursue
kim yong-ha's
podcast and possibly other content i
know that i will get more and more used
to the language
and as i eventually start to speak it
i'll eventually become more accurate in
in my usage and to me that's just a
normal process
and so i don't worry about what i can't
do what i don't
can't produce correctly it's just not
something that
bothers me at all so on that note i'm
gonna cut it off here and go off and
watch the hockey game bye for now